In this video,
we'll complete our description of the
contrasted divergence algorithm as applied
to every sector,
both the machine and get an actual
concrete parameter update rule.
Yeah.
And the previous video we've talked
about how to estimate the negative log
probability gradient.
We needed to estimate this
a double expectation over
both x and h in the model.
And then,
uh,
this justified because this is actually
attracted book with them to Compute is
justified in approximation
and you contrasted divergence.
The idea is to replace this expectation
by a point estimate where we'll actually
just simple a single value for x
and a to obtain that value of x,
which we'll call [inaudible].
We actually perform a few steps of gib
sampling initialized at the current
training observation.
So now let's look at how we can in the
context of a restricted Boltzmann machine
compute this fall, uh, update, uh,
assuming that we've performed a,
a few steps of gib sampling at starting
at the current trainee example.
X.
T
yeah.
Okay. Um, we need, uh,
to perform a few more their
vacations to get the full algorithm.
So I remember that we have to perform
an expectation over age of the partial
derivative of the energy with
respect to any parameter.
So let's do first the partial derivative
of the energy with respect to uh,
any prevnar.
So actually we'll just do the case for
the connection between a Djf hidden unit
and the kief input.
So the partial do they have of the energy
with respect to a connection is does
the partial there, they've of this,
that's just the energy function.
And we notice that there's only one
term which involves this particular
connection between h j and x.
K.
So really to be a strictly correct,
I should have a j prime and k prime.
But just to simplify,
I'm using the same indices. Um, um,
but you should understand
what's going on here.
So really this whole
some here in particular,
this sum here is the only one
that involves connections.
So the partial [inaudible]
affected this or that is zero.
And then the only term here that involves
exactly the same connection between HD
and ex gay is the one that
involves HJ index gay.
So the partial derivative of that here
is really the partial [inaudible] of the
term Wj k times h j Aix, Aix, k
for the same value of j and k.
And uh, this is a term that's linear
in my parameter, so it's value,
it's just whatever it was multiplying
that weight, which is h j o n x game.
And then I get them minus which was here.
And so if I want to put that into matrix
form so they get the grade and that the
energy with respect to the full matrix
w then you should be able to see that
this is just mine as the outer
product of the age vector with the,
uh, transport. So with the, the
x factors, or in other words,
the Matrix product between the column
vector minus the column vector,
h times their row vector x.
Now,
if we perform the expectation with respect
to age condition on any value of the
factor x, so, uh, we have this,
we're trying to do this for a
theater equals to our connection. Uh,
so we've shown that this is equal
to that here minus h j times x.
K. Um, so this is, uh,
an expectation over all neurons in the
hidden there h but this involves on the
one had in neuron a DJ at hidden neuron.
So really this is just
a, some uh, over, uh,
that neuron being called two zero,
one of the term that we have here,
but waited by the probability that HJ
is equal equal to it's given value.
And I notice that in this,
um, there's two cases, uh,
HD equals to zero. HP, h j sorry,
equals zero h j equals two one
if Hja zero, then this is zero.
And otherwise this term is
just that equals to one.
And so that's the only non zero terms.
So really this is just
equivalent to minus X.
Gay Times are probably that
Aisha is equal to one given x,
which is given right here.
And again,
if we want to write this into matrix
form, um, then we know this again,
that we could write this as the
other product of minus a vector,
which I'm going to call h of x,
which is the vector that contains the
probability of each hidden unit being
equal to one given X.
I put that into a vector and a notice
that this is just the sigmoid of,
uh,
the bias vector plus the
Matrix of weights w times x.
So I take that vector
Hvacs, uh, and I, uh,
do the other product with
the vector x. And so the, uh,
entry in that matrix at ro,
uh,
Jay and columnK is going
to be exactly this.
So none of this also that conveniently,
uh,
h of x is actually just the value of
hidden layer in a feed for neural network
with sigmoidal activation function.
Uh,
this is somewhat of a
coincidence, but, uh, it start
seeing that, you know, this is,
this is really a neural network.
There are relationships between the
restrictive Bolsa machine and, uh, uh, uh,
neural networks.
And so if we put everything
together, it means that, eh,
for a given a training example
and a negative sample that I've,
uh,
simple with case steps of gib sampling
initialize that XD some calling that x
stilled.
Uh,
then if I want to update w
by Matrix of connections,
then want to take w minus some learning
rate of an estimator of the gradient of
the negative log probability of
the observed training sample.
We've seen that this expression
was the difference between a,
a positive phase and a negative phase,
the positive phase and expectation
condition on the observation.
And the other one's an expectation where
I'm also taking the expectation over
the x factor.
Uh,
then I've argued that I
can compute this exactly.
So what I'll do is that I'll
replace this double expectation, uh,
with a point estimate where I'm
going to a sample, a value for x,
which I'm calling instilled
and I'm given x still.
I can actually do the remaining part
of the expectation over H and. N.
I've shown that, uh, in a
four and the value of x,
this expectation with correspond to
my h of x vector or four XD cause I'm
conditioning our XD here, uh, uh,
multiply by the transpose of XD and
then this which has the same form,
but instead of conditioning on x
IX stilled, that's going to be uh,
age stilled times the
transpose of external.
So I combine that together and
multiply this by uh, Alpha.
And then I can just increment w by that.
Okay.
So notice we had a minus
here and the minus there.
So that's why there's no minus here
anymore. We have a plus here but,
and then we have a minus here.
So to sum up the sort of go for a
contrasted divergence corresponds to,
uh,
going over to training examples for the
current training example performed case
steps of Gib sampling to obtain
a negative sample x stilled and,
and I update my parameters.
So I have the update for the Matrix W
I'll leave it as an exercise to show that
we get a similar update for B and c.
Uh,
so it's going to be what is
observed minus what I've sampled.
So for the sea vector,
which is the bias for x,
I get a term that involves x.
And for the B vector, which, uh,
is a bias for the hidden units,
then I get the vector of
probabilities as, uh, given, uh,
condition on either x or x tilt.
And so,
and then I keep doing this
until some stopping criteria.
So for instance, if I, uh,
until my parameters don't change too
much or for a fixed number of a parameter
which I could cross
validate somehow, uh, uh,
using some given criteria
of generalization.
So, uh, this is, uh, uh,
so the acronym we use code for contrast
advisor divergence is CD and sometimes
you'll see CD dash gave,
uh, where I explicitly, uh,
illustrate what's the value
of, of, of gay. Um, so,
uh, so the number of
gifts as assembling steps,
the bigger key is the less biased our
estimate of the gradient is going to be.
So if k was very,
very large and it means that my gifts
chain would have essentially converged to
the true model of distribution.
And so I just get a Monte Carlo estimate
of the expectation. So in other words,
in expectation,
this estimate would be with
corresponds to the true expectation.
Um, and now the, the, the,
the less k is big, however,
uh, the less it's going
to be, uh, the more bias.
There's going to be my estimate of the,
uh, uh, negative log likelihood gradient.
However, it turns out that to
extract some features or uh,
to initialize neural networks,
which we call pre training,
which is something we'll discuss
later in this course. Uh,
k equals one works well
in practice. And, um,
so there's been some research for
trying to understand why that is.
The initial paper and contrasted
divergence was trying to argue that, uh,
you know, this, this
actually makes sense. Um,
and so we'll just live with the fact that,
and we are actually quite happy with this,
that k equals one.
So performing just one sample of age and
then immediately resembling IX stilled
actually provides a,
a is a good procedure for getting a
meaningful value for x still in order to
learn a, uh, learn a good value of,
of hidden units, uh, at least
in terms of extracting features.
Um,
however,
if we were to look at how
good the model is and,
uh,
it turns out that using larger
values of k is actually beneficial.
That is if we look at, um, uh,
whether the value of the,
uh,
average negative log probability of,
a test set, for instance, um,
if k becomes bigger than typically,
this will be much better.
But in terms of just extracting features
that is getting a good value of the
vector h of x,
uh,
which we could then use as a feature
representation for another learning
algorithm. It turns out that key equals
one works well in practice. All right,
so that summarizes the
contrasted divergence algorithms.